assalamualaikum warahmatullah better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends welcome to this video and now
this video is going to be intentional
interesting informative and there'll be
a lot of clarity inshaallah on my stance
on certain matters now guys before you
guys watch this video i would really
appreciate if you can watch all the way
through if you're gonna watch this for
two minutes three minutes and five
minutes or whatever it may be and turn
off and jump to assumptions it's best if
you don't watch it but I would prefer
that you watch it in full now guys
there's few questions that people ask me
and I've always asked me regarding
certain things that I do now when it
comes to advising public figures out
there etc I'm out they they ask me
questions like why do I do what I do you
know what what is the reason why do you
have to mention another YouTube or
another brother by name what is the
reason and of course people ask this
question and I genuinely want to answer
this so we can have a common
understanding of why we do what we do
now before I start I need to make sure
you guys understand my intention of
doing this video number one is do I get
paid by YouTube do I make money of you
should because if I make money of
YouTube then you have every right to
jump to assumptions to say you know what
brother Ali you're just doing these
click baits and these videos because you
get paid by YouTube you want views and
by making by getting these views you get
paid so what we're going to do is we're
gonna I'm going to show you guys every
single YouTube video of mine and show
you guys do I make a single penny on
YouTube yeah so let you quickly go
through that yeah as you can see on the
screen guys that from all of my videos
as I scroll down you can see very
clearly that I do not make a penny on
YouTube and I don't want to make a penny
on YouTube that's my personal preference
and so that's clear for you guys now
now that we've overcome Dan you've seen
that that this is not about money now
the second question you could say to me
is Riley okay you're not doing it for
money you're doing it for fame now with
that there's nothing I can show you if
an elitist that I'm not doing it for
fame but I have the Quran in front of me
and this is the book of Allah
yeah and we try to live by it as much as
possible we're not perfect but I'm
telling you guys on this very video that
I swear by Allah if I am doing this
video for faith if I'm doing this for
fame what Allah he by Allah yeah I'm not
taking off by the what I don't think
Oprah Allah but I'll have to find my
hand yeah I just want to tell you guys
I'm saying I take her off by Allah
subhanAllah
I'm not doing this for fame so now two
things are very clear am i doing it for
money I've shown you you guys you've
seen yourself I don't get paid
number two am i doing it for fame I
swore by Allah and if a believer swears
by Allah you have to believe in you have
the no option if you do not believe him
you have a problem within yourself
now that we've overcome these two let's
move forward let's move forward to why
I'm doing this video now guys brother
Khalid is a brother that I met maybe
around eight nine months ago 19 months
ago he's when I first name is a lovely
brother yeah I have I have nothing bad
to say about the brother his character
when I first met him I've seen nothing
but good from the brother he's a lad his
manners the way he is an ecology from
what I've seen the bomber practices
mashallah may Allah bless him he does
good reminders etc if the brother called
me if you need anything any kind of help
well I I'm here for him and his team you
know as a brother he's my he's another
brother in Islam and I love him for the
sake of Allah it's nothing personal and
brother khalid knows this right but all
of us make mistakes I make a lot of
mistakes in my private life in my public
life I make a lot of mistakes I'm not
perfect the reason I'm doing this video
is not to show I'm perfect a brother
holid is not perfect this is not my
intention to bring him down it's not my
intentions but unfortunately wait when
we make these mistakes in public this is
when the problem comes because when
these issues are made in public and we
have a following as a youtuber myself I
have to be very careful to who I work
with you know and this doesn't mean it's
because I'm righteous it's not that I'm
in the Dawa if I go and work with
another individual let's see for example
I work with a barber who's on YouTube
who goes clubbing who smoke he's with
girls etc if I'm chilling with him
you're gonna Finn brothers Ali it's
chilling with him he's doing these bad
things abroad Ali's okay with it so the
thing here is guys is that it's a I have
to clarify my stance on it now guys
about five months ago five and a half
months ago brother had got in contact
with me regarding working together on a
video and I was I was happy I was happy
to work with him Ida said okey I'll come
to Birmingham so I traveled to Burman go
I went to see brother Holly now as I
went there obviously was waiting for the
braava mashallah Mela blessing he came
we spoke now before we
it's work together I had to make
something very clear I told brother
Hallett looking a prophet may allah
bless you
I've seen your work I've shared your
words I like your works now I said
brother brother holid we're gonna do a
video together obviously before we do I
said please forgive me for asking this
vice just for my own clarity I just said
brother hala do you believe music to be
permissible this was my question because
I was he was doing the she's etc I had
to clarify my point because I
specifically asked because I did not
want to be in this dilemma today that I
am and this is the reason why I am here
because I did this video with him and he
said to me as far as I can remember
as far as I can remember it clearly said
to me that he doesn't believe music to
be permissible this is what I remember
this is what I remember and I might be
mistaken but I am very sure along those
lines but one thing that I'm really
certain about is brother Han it said the
reason why he abstains from music is
because he affected enough this is what
he told Nia and I follow quash all other
brothers you know he's been honest in
his being sincere Lee's he's telling me
this he said it fixes enough so I said
okay look at you that's normal because
you know music for me back in the day
his music I know how it was I never did
drugs I never drank alcohol you know I
never did like you know ecstasy or
whether you may call it but one thing
that played the big role in my life was
music music was like my drug you know
and forgive me for mention this is just
so you guys can benefit when I would go
to these evil places or nightclubs or
whatever it may be music would take me
to another dimension
and that's why I believe this reason why
I believe music is haram majority of the
scholars out there they believe it's
Haram you know so that's why I
understood where Kim's when he said he
affects my nuts cuz I knew where he's
coming from I've been there so I
understood but I said look a Camille I
bless you clarify that to me I have no
problem working with you so basically we
did a hell out dining with the Bravo I
pushed it out of been propagating
brother Hallett since then some of the
works that it does now guys I don't know
if you guys remember but I released a
video on youtube about a couple of
months ago called Muslim youtubers
starter pack I did this video to show
like guys there's a responsibility that
comes with it you know keep that in mind
that these views these young brothers
this is watching this are gonna be
affected
now when you go into the video I'm gonna
show you guys right now we're gonna
watch
together I go through the pub
Association and funnily enough I
actually mentioned by the Hallett why I
don't associate myself with everybody
now as a youtuber is so important for me
to know who I'm working with now example
I'm gonna give it and I've asked about
permission is well a blessing it's
brother Khalid he's a new youtuber and I
followed his stuff you know and
obviously I followed his stuff
and I found a brother sincere I found
him sincere I found his lackeys add up
on point brothers and mail are keeping
firm on that may Allah keep him firm on
that yeah now I personally believe music
is Haram
I personally believe music is all wrong
yeah so I spoke to brother Khalid met
brother Khalid and we was planning on
doing a video now before I did this
video and the brother knows as well I
said look aqui
yeah you're my brother I love you in the
dome above I love you if you need
anything whatever I will try my best to
help you but in the public scene a key
we need to understand something that I
said turn our key do you believe music
is permissible and this is not me saying
hey you need to believe that this is
just seen look ucky
I believe it's impermissible what's your
opinion because if we're gonna work
together and you don't mind using music
then what happens is not that you're a
bad person but if you think that is
correct and you want to put that out
then people are gonna think ok music is
ok brother Ali welcome Judy I'm Janice a
and we came to an agreement
etc and I fought a key I have no problem
working with you now guys as you saw for
yourself in that video this was done
four or five months ago
that I clearly say when it comes to
Association why we have to be careful
who we work with and I give an example
of Hallett because we've had it you know
I spoke to him etc I asked him does he
believe music permissible
he said no and I start working with him
now the issue here is this problem
sisters brother Hallett has come to
change his opinion of certain matters
what I can say on a big matters big
matters I'm not gonna go into detail
which I disagree with brother Khalid
even though other YouTube is started
doing videos against brother Khalid and
advising him etc I took a stand back and
I said you know what I need to observe
look I've got the robbers number I can
call him I can speak with him I can meet
with him we can talk and we had I had an
agreement on a higher set up by the
holiday let's just have an agreements
with both have come to understand again
you now believe music for missable now
you put me in a tight spot
the corner now yeah I'm in a corner
where I asked you specifically my
prophet you've been in musicals what he
said no now I don't blame you now you've
change your opinion okay I don't blame
you
but you need to understand it's kinda
having a have an impact on me because
I've worked with you I have to do so
[ __ ] myself and say look brother hired
me a blessing because good work success
rate my baby maybe but I am a part of
that and I just need associate myself
right and this is the video I'm doing
today I have to do this video now our
agreement was brother holid you bring
your teacher that says music is
permissible I'll bring my teacher we'll
look at the evidences and we go from
there and I said brother hand if you can
genuinely show me that music is
permissible I'm ready to join you on
your journey with music our being in the
[ __ ] videos music videos whatever you
like yeah but if it's not my brother I
believe you're sincere and you will
leave this opinion that music
permissible the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him said they will come a time a
certain people in my own mob will make
Zinner music silk and our core
permissible now the fact that these are
all measuring this category shows you
the severity Prophet Muhammad peace
prepare not or neither of his companions
none of them listen to music especially
of the ones today
you know we've got individuals coming up
and using musical backgrounds or some
allowed words and fingers permissible
it's not
don't play Wallace wanton in his
religion don't play you know just say if
you know it's not permissible it's not
permissible
there's no reason of working your way
around the etc but me and brother a
halide had an agreement for our teachers
to me unfortunately I was in contact
with his team and they said that they
were ready to meet my teacher in around
October I said okay that's not a problem
that's fine my teacher is happy to do
that
however as Jew time came true to me nice
man it's my job to assume the best that
maybe the teacher was busy he said that
they you know they want to meet me first
and then after meeting me first they
want to meet my teacher so obviously I
was ok with that but then I was that
look when longing things out don't just
meet and let's see if this matter is as
clear as you say you know because I'd
strongly believe music is haram you know
but I was just saying look I go there
let's see cuz I believed now you know if
I go there and show the evidence it's a
brother holiday since anyone I've seen
from your using music however that
didn't happen now I don't want to go too
much in detail I'm gonna put a link for
Islam Q&A which will clearly
oh you why music is not immiscible why
it is Haram
now bear this in mind a lot of people
were approaching me and saying brother
Ali why do you make your stance clear
look the brothers you know starting to
use musical instruments now that put me
in an awkward situation because I was
like hi little my brother lucky my head
off thinking I told you this before you
know but you know you're going down the
chute he put me in this in very tight
position I spoke to my teachers you know
they say look just give it some time
speak with him I tried my best
however about I think a week ago a
couple of days ago brother had released
a video now in this video it really like
it was like the last straw for me like
cuz I had to think to myself okay what
am I gonna do now because now holid is
out right promoting music Sufi music you
know now I said let me just listen to
him listen to and hopefully it's not as
bad as I think now brother Hallett is
playing this video he's doing a reaction
he's you're in reaction yeah is I think
is indirectly promoting it he's doing a
reaction video to it now I had two
issues like the first one I didn't
really know what the lady was talking
about I didn't really get a chance to
even really understand it however the
second one is of a qawalli kind of type
of music
now Boden says I want us both to just
watch that for a second right now the
fact that there is this lady in the
Alice want Allah says in the Quran don't
even come near zina don't even come near
it
meaning if you know is here work your
way around it that meaning go around the
block just to avoid it but if you look
in in the music video you've got a woman
amongst men clapping singing saying Ali
Ali Ali
for example now this is that could
invitation what what you're trying to
basically say that like indirectly is
free mixing is okay it's okay let's to
come together with sisters and brothers
and you know just do whatever you like
you know because you need to understand
music and zina play hunter and I've seen
this in my jahiliya I've seen it in
nightclubs
women and men alcohol music what did the
politician say there will come a time
where alcohol music and zina will be
permissible so I'm asking you guys
imagine look once again I'll be in a
nightclub what you need what ingredients
were
disaster alcohol music free mixin so
guys I'm just kindly asking that brother
hundred maybe unintentionally put this
out there please for the sake of a lot
my brother just take it down and
inshallah if you believe musics
permissible then make it clear for the
people your stance on the matter so
people are aware because if you do
machinima Brava saying that there is no
musical instruments not people are a bit
confused because you seem like you know
you put some music in some places you
don't like what's the purpose behind it
if I believe music from so I'm gonna see
guys I believe music is permissible
that's it that's my stance so then
people can say you know what I don't
want to listen to music any of these
videos can come up with music I'm gonna
abstain so I'm not brother holidays may
Allah grant you gender may Allah bless
you please let's just be clear on this
matter on that video brother sisters
this quality music is being played now I
have two issues with this before a third
major finger rised in this video now
there is music being played number one
yeah now I am thinking in my head I
wanted to meet brother Khalid things
have been prolonged now brother holidays
going and outright propagating music
yeah like again I am NOT here to
belittle the brother in any shape or
form but I just want to show you the
dangers of music you can see by the
highest starting to nod his head right
he's he's not in his head now this is
one of the effects that music has on
your brain it has on your body you can't
help but move yourself you know now
brother Hallett as you can see on the
video while this isn't please before I
come to the video he is starting to
dance now once this going on you can see
brother highlight he's starting to move
his body now brothers and sisters what
kind of impression is that given to his
viewers what kind of impression is given
to his viewers now before I get back get
into the video I want to play a short
video scientifically showing you guys
something from its from science that how
the music has an effect on you let's
watch that and understand and we're
going to come back straight to this what
I'm saying is your brain treats music
differently in fact at the peak
emotional time during a song dopamine is
released in the brain stri Adam this is
the same neurotransmitter involved in
more tangible pleasures like food sex
and drugs and apparently rock and roll
even more along with the peak emotional
times dopamine is also released during
the anticipation of the
times so basically listening to music
and your brain is encouraging you to
keep doing it through the release of
dopamine now we know the quran assume
that tells us music is not a rap music
is not permissible yes science backs
that up yeah we don't need science to
back up our science is there telling you
it has an effect on your body yeah
so my first issue is this the fact that
music has this effect on your body it's
like a high that it gives you which I
believe that which is one of the reasons
I believe is Haram now let's go to the
video brothers and sisters in the video
we've got a group of people that they
are charging something Ali Aleeah now
there is a female amongst them playing
this music musical instrument and
singing along this is free mixing
brother the highlight you yourself don't
free mix as far as I know you don't feel
mix my brother yeah you are pushing this
out there number two music IKEA the
matter of music a key we asked and we
pleaded review to sit down let's talk
about the matter and look into the
evidences yeah but before you doing that
and you don't see that click evidences
from our side
you are propagating this my brother and
especially when I've talked to you yeah
now what is more disturbing this this my
brothers and sisters because once I show
this to my teacher he said to me this
group you know does these kind of koala
things and some of it or most of it is
ship now obviously a lot of you guys
wear black our common Ravalli ship now
now you're going and you go into
something else here now promises if I
said to you guys I believe allies my
lord
yes I live for Allah Allah is a master
Allah is the master and I do they can on
last name like I lose myself would you
have a problem with that statement would
you say to me brother Ali why are you
saying that no however what if I told
you guys stuff Allah would be lamination
eternal if I said to you guys I live for
Ali Ali is a master Ali is the master
and basically the wicked in his name now
anyone that has some understanding of
Sheikh will understand the fitrah
rejecting that saying whoa hold on a
second Ottoman Ali's Vemma
what do you mean I live for Ali what do
you mean idolater Ali's name now this is
the same group that does this and I have
spoken to brother khalid and his team
and i kindly kindly kindly actually
begged and pleaded and said please would
you take that video Dharma Bravo and do
a clarification
however due to certain circumstances
whatever they said that brother Hallett
did not play any part of [ __ ] or
whatever it may be you know they said
that you know that bit rather highly cut
out or something like that now brothers
and sisters I want to show you guys for
your very own self let's watch with our
own very own eyes - what stamens these
individuals are uttering I am
intoxicated with the calendar it has
made all things oblivious with the
repetition of Ali Ali I am intoxicated
with the calendar and I live for him
through the state of intoxication it's
not the day even smaller one will have
to say Ali Ali Oh everything is
annihilated in him and I am intoxicated
with McClendon Ali is my master Ali is
the master they live for him I live
through the state of complete
annihilation I'm intoxicated with the
calendar now guys you saw that with your
very own eyes now my first issue was
with the music and if we mix it yes and
the fact that brother holid is not only
propagating that indirectly and the fact
that he's saying when I feel down when I
feel like you know down I'm going to
play that you know to get me back into
the whatever it may be here one of it
may be yeah now I have an issue with
that not only that but the fact that
these individuals are at the same words
of comfort is this is shik this is [ __ ]
now brothers and sisters I want you guys
to hold on I want to open a restitution
of the Quran yeah and this is and I
don't mean to like attack anyone in a
shape or form yeah but though for those
of you who have heard that qawalli group
playing what they're playing I'm not
going to play for you guys
what kind of impact it has on your heart
yeah and I'm not seeing this that
brother Hallett doesn't listen to for I
don't see in that at all I just want you
guys to understand where I'm coming from
now I want you guys to listen to this
Quran verse brothers and sisters and
tell me what effect it has in your heart
let's listen together and shop
bismillah Aparna Fahim one of kabuki huh
bismillah image ad hahaha not be love a
photo for here one here teddy bins emoji
Kelly G bar
and one here at achieving entomology
ecology daddy wanna die nor phony Benham
one under nor phony burner who I can I
see Mars in here
I'm gonna you're gonna yeah when Al
became my my look LCD
be honest are we launch of any same
morning in Allah
ah now guys we heard it for ourselves
wallahi but Quran is the medicine for
the heart even came said music and Quran
can't be in the same hot it can not be
in the same hot now guys you listen for
yourself now I'm not trying to have a
dig at brother Hallett I'm not trying to
have a go I am and I truly hope that he
does he's not upset with me I'm only
doing this for the sake of Allah for you
guys not to be misguided unintentionally
I'm not saying brother Kyle goes out
then does it intentionally now to say
that when I feel down I want to listen
to this like I'm not trying to nitpick
but brothers sisters when we are feeling
down I think that Iran is the best
remedy for us the word of Allah is the
best remedy for us now I'm not gonna act
all pious and say I listen to Quran
twenty four seven years I listen to the
sheets I believe this is not permissible
those who don't have [ __ ] don't have a
bitter that don't have music and foul
language right this is another topic but
this is what I believe but now Quran is
something else prophet insisted so
something that contains or for example
is from a group that sugar net and let's
see but I know brother holiday I'll
intentionally put that out there but if
it's done unintentionally why is it so
hard just to delete that video and just
clarify because this is [ __ ] this is not
something it's not like a little job
thing guys
she'll gets on with us couldn't if you
die upon silk its end off for you
this is end of is the biggest sin in
Islam now if I was to put anything
indicating a little bit of [ __ ] I have
to take that down and clarify for the
people so I'm just asking about the
Holly please for the sake of Allah if
you can please take this video down so
guys hope you have benefited please
share this video and Charlotte's what
other people can benefit my stance is
clear on this matter I taught you to
disagree with surfing brother holiday
doing and I free myself from that not in
an arrogant way so hope you guys have
benefited once again
inshaallah me last month allah grant
every single one of you guys jannah
assalamualaikum warahmatullah america
too